what has been a rough night for him  shooting-wise he's now in double figures  with 11.  and holiday picks up his foul that's the  third on holiday they actually took one  away from him earlier and gave it to t  well they're having some  miscommunication on some pick and rolls  there two go to chris paul leaving  booker  wide open and like his dad  melvin used to quote the great jay-z  go further go farther if not why bother  that jvg quoting  you wanted to be a rapper last game now  all of a sudden you you have a down path  beautiful pass paul to ayton  i'll tell you what deandre ayton's got  down pat scream for print quest ball  and roll to that rim holiday gets inside  just using his strength to get the layup  103.92  suns by 11. six and a half remaining  here in game two